what is it about there's still a lot of
people out there that are nervous about
social they're worried about security
they're worried about who's gonna hack
this and hack that and I don't want to
touch it I don't want to be out there
and they're hurting themselves very
talented people can you talk to the
security a little bit or what you know
of and and the fears and maybe put down
some of these fears that people have
there's in my or in my head there's - I
really break people down into two groups
people that are on the offense and
people that are on the defense you're
just talking about people that are on
the defense I don't really know what
else to say you know I think privacy is
dead I actually think it doesn't matter
at all I mean we just went through the
biggest privacy issue in American
history and nobody gives a [ __ ] right
who cares right and so the truth is I
think mainstream media for a long time
has portrayed us human beings as bad you
turn on the news if you just watch the
news your whole life you would think
human beings are the worst thing of all
time right but when you look at the data
it is stunning how good we really are
yeah it's shocking how many bad things
we could do to each other and how little
we actually do to each other and so you
know I think that I think that as time
goes on people are clearly becoming less
and less private things that were taboo
and scary and look all you have to do is
look at society right Miley Cyrus right
everybody gets all bent out of shape
about twerking and they forget that the
long hair of the Beatles was the same
issue or that when Elvis shook his hips
that that was the devil I mean if these
were real articles yeah right or that
like gangster rap right like you know I
mean like to Live Crew was gonna make me
shoot a cop you know I mean it's it's
ludicrous and so we're living through
you know a time in a period where we're
just reenacting history was repeating
itself over and over and over we become
more and more extreme versions of what
we've been as you know as the churches
and different things become less of the
guiding Northstar in our society and I
think it's quite healthy I think people
are happier in general and I think that
you know I think a lot of people said a
lot of people make the wrong decision
you know no matter what I say to your
question right now and they're scared
they'll continue to be they won't do
they won't put in the work
they'll be fearful or whatever maybe and
they'll lose I mean a lot of people lose
a lot a lot a lot a lot of people lose
that's kind of fun for me of capitalism
and business I'd prefer them not to lose
in life I want them to use these
platforms to stay in touch with their
family think about all the people that
are jumped on Facebook in their 40s 50s
and 60s that have reconnected with
people that they hadn't talked to in 20
years and have more value in like
rehashed good stories things that are
good for the soul I think there's a lot
of good